welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the boys
gen V Episode 5 welcome to the monster
Club where we find out what the deal was
with that weird time Jump blackout at
the end of episode 4 I am really digging
this show just as much as the boys so
let's dive into all the Easter eggs all
the details you missed and just take a
look at all the clues from both of these
shows to try to make some guesses about
what is going on in the woods and
exactly who Marie's mysterious
benefactor is okay we open on this clear
goo dripping onto Andre's sleeping face
and in the world of genv unidentified
fluid is never anything good we do
eventually see what that goo was coming
from and well how to describe this let's
just say I thought we were done with
holes on this show Marie is the only one
who's having memory problems Kate and
Andre don't know where they are either
or how they got there Andre right it
turns out they are in someone named
Dusty's house and The Telltale frat boy
party signs are all around them there
are some red Solo cups a trains turbo
Rush energy drink old beer boxes used as
wallpaper a discarded pizza box vot a
burger fry box v a burger and a silver
tray with what looks like baggies of
cocaine on it in the hallway they greet
what I assume is a soup who's an alpaka
or maybe a llama by the name of Sloan
who has Maverick on a leash with a ball
gag in his mouth and I like how just by
the gag itself and his hat and classes
we know what's going on here Andrea and
Kate pass by a room with a mermaid
looking woman covered in shimmery scales
and a guy who does a line of coke and
then breathes fire we also saw a fire
breathing a couple weeks ago in the
woods there are various ma Starlight
homelander and black noir magazine
pictures on the wall in the room that
Jordan Marie wake up in Jordan hands
Marie the bra but interestingly Jordan
doesn't wear one maybe this is a comfort
thing when they shift from a female
Persona to the male Persona Emma wakes
up big in a pool even bigger than how we
saw her last episode with no memory of
recent events using a pool cover as a
blanket there's a sign for Route 420 on
the fence in the style of an interstate
sign there were actually plans to build
an interstate 420 in at Atlanta but it
never happened can you imagine how many
times that sign would have been stolen
Emma asks Marie to find her a place to
puke so that she can return to her
normal size imagine the amount of puke
that would have come out and then they
watch Tik Tok to figure out what
happened at the party the account is @
super kid with a dollar sign as an S and
a backwards D and then the caption is
last night's party was lit a f Marie and
Jordan make out on the Dance Floor
something that could affect the rankings
of two of the top five in future
episodes and a huge naked Emma chugging
an entire ceg of beer which is just
hilarious now Emma reveals that she knew
that she could get big but promised her
mother she would never do it again ever
since quote the Buster Beaver incident
Buster beaver's pizza restaurant is a
parody of Chuck-E-Cheese in the universe
of the boys the restaurant's cartoon
mascots are the ones that black noir
imagined he was interacting with in the
boys season 3 but after the incident
that Emma went through Emma's mom called
her a monster a word that we'll hear
again a couple times this episode Marie
rubs her clavicle in an absent-minded
way which become really important later
she's already sensing that something's
clotted and stuck in there the the room
that Marie and Emma are sitting in has
more frat boy trappings like a big
cardboard cutout a Starlight in her dawn
of the S outfit a street sign that says
superhero Square in a Saturday's refer
the boys Banner a phrase that was made
Popular by bar stool sports but also a
clever play on words for the boys you
know the show that the show is spun off
from Sam shows up still wearing dead
Greg's jumpsuit from last episode but
they have no memory of him they made you
forget Emma there are
dangerous evil people at that school
people that don't want you to know about
me or the truth it sounds like Sam isn't
just talking about the woods here and
there might be multiple evil plots going
down at gulan as Sam runs off he bunks
into one of those red Solo cups which
might have been a mistake they just left
in just like this famous
bonan take over Emma and Marie walk by
these banners one that reads beer time
it's 5:00 somewhere and another for
translucent vodka they'll never see it
coming we learn more about Marie's
powers that guy had literal blood under
his fingernails and it wasn't his God
your powers are
Bonkers wait when am I going to get my
parod again holy Emma what I lost track
you're insane I mean next Friday though
we keep learning about Marie's unique
power set setting up Dr cardo's
statement about her abilities later the
others tell Marie that they also can't
remember the past few days and she tells
them about Sam showing up and notice
that Kate does not immediately tell the
others that Sam is the name of Luke's
brother just a little hint early on this
episode that you know something's up
with her she's not what she says she is
we meet a new student the party host
Dusty a soup who looks like a kid but is
really the age 28 which is also really
funny because you're 28 you're just one
of those guys who stays at the college
town and continues hosting parties for
people who are like you know right on
the edge of people you should be hanging
out with but physically he's on the
bottom side of that looking like a kid
so yeah it's got to suck when he's
trying to buy beer but also might be a
nod to the character sprite from
eternals other than that we don't really
know what his powers are yet but we did
see another seen with him in a trailer
for geny so he'll definitely be back on
the show oh one shot energy huh I think
I'll try
it
[Applause]
w so what does one shot's Focus shoe
[Music]
do
it
[Music]
turn
wa so uh one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with oneshot
energy today by going to oneshot
energy.com rockars were 10% off your
order Kate shifts the blame for their
memory issues onto Rufus who did
recently ruy Marie with his powers so
the others obviously don't question this
but Dr cardosa tells Dean Shetty that
he's done dealing with Sam you know
since Sam tried to Mur murder him in
front of his family last episode and he
expresses concern about what Marie and
the others know butched tells them that
they've been quote handled and we get
this interesting exchange I am this fing
close to perfecting the virus a viable
way to control them for good but if they
discover
that I'm not pay nearly enough to die
for this shito so my guess is what Dr
cardosa is working on is similar to The
Legacy virus from X-Men a plague that
affected mutants before it mutated and
started killing non- mutants as well bot
is always looking for some ways to
control or subdue the soups that they
created like gas that was used against
Soldier Boy even hiding homelander son
away from him in case they needed to use
him to kill homelander but a virus that
Target soups would allow them to kill
off anyone that became too powerful or
too hard to control shedy asks cardosa
what it is that he wants and he says I
want the girl Marie her ability are the
rarest I've ever seen she's the perfect
subject could speed up my
timeline she is special but no she has a
benefactor and because of that she's
strictly off limits another mystery so
who is this mysterious benefactor and
what does cardosa mean about Marie being
the perfect subject I have theories
about who both Marie's benefactor is and
what cardosa means by this and I'm going
to get to those a little bit later so
after her big night Emma has a slew of
new fans including this guy who tells
her that she has big soup energy we
actually see him in the trailer using
his ice breath power to create a luge in
a dorm hallway so this guy's coming back
we see Jordan also scratching their
collar bone when talking to Marie and
they spot Rufus talking with Dean shett
Marie says that she doesn't trust Dean
Shetty so clearly she remembers some
stuff in the last few days even if it's
just a feeling of unease around that
shady Dean she hasn't lost her Edge from
her time at the Red River Institute it's
good to let the audience know that she's
not falling for shed's attempts to gain
her trust Rufus bolts when he sees
Jordan and Marie and pays Benny 20 bucks
to take his shape Benny has powers like
doppelganger in the boys who we last saw
getting their neck snapped by homelander
like doppelganger Benny can't replicate
clothes he's wearing a different outfit
than Rufus was and they should have
caught that Benny shouts at Jordan that
he's allowed to take someone's shape
when he has permission highlighting
again the theme of powers and consent
you know I could take my glove off and
make
you I won't cuz I'm all about consent
considering what's revealed about Kate
this episode her earlier comment is
particularly nefarious in rufus's dorm
room there's a sign next to the door
that reads in the event of a code red
all students must remain in their dorms
until given further instruction Andre
uses his poers to close the metal
Shutters on the door and windows these
safety measures along with that weird
metal detector looking thing that Marie
walked through in episode 1 make me
think that a code red might be when a
soup loses it and goes on a killing
spree remember Emma pointed out that
there were bars on the window to keep
students from jumping on all the dorm
room windows it kind of feels like this
is part of that all of these characters
are really in a prison that is just
above ground and dressed up to look like
a college campus all of these things are
designed not only to keep the students
safe but also to isolate them and to
keep the non-powered people safe from
the soups so we could be looking at a
covs code red situation here where by
the end of the season in we will see
these metallic barricades playing a much
larger role and a code red will actually
happen ruus denies doing anything to the
group and then uses his powers to make
Andre black out he comes to at a VOD
burger with a long line of people behind
him waiting to Chow Down on some of
homelanders Liberty fries in the deeps
calamari poppers but thanks to her big
Antics Emma finally broke into gulen's
top 100 and she finds a Stardust
Drive-In shirt that she was wearing last
episode so she knows Sam was telling the
truth and speaking of Sam he's still
hearing voices and seeing puppets and we
get this amazing all puppet hyper
violent fight scene it starts with
puppet Sam throwing down his magazine
and getting into a fighting stance
making fists so hard we hear his
knuckles
crack which reminds me of this Bruce Lee
moment in way of the
Dragon it's also kind of like the Neo
agent Smith Subway fight in the Matrix
but Sam punches this first guy who's
holding a gun and sparkly red confetti
bursts out in place of blood then he
rips the second guy's arms off and
little X's appear on his eyes right
before Sam tears his head off two more
guys shoot at Sam and then the bullets
are just pieces of popcorn Sam is
unfazed by the shots so he must be
bulletproof like soldier boy or
homelander he punches one guy to death
before tearing off the last guy's arm
bending it in half and then shoving it
in the guy's mouth then he rips one
guy's spine out before snapping another
guy's head around and ripping out his
brain and the guy who's repelling down
from the helicopter swings towards Sam
who completely rips the lower half of
his body off and then the last puppet
begs for his life I have a single dad
with two daughters their names are haly
Sam rips him in half sparkly red
confetti spurting out the imaginary Emma
puppet watches and I like how they show
that she's imaginary by having her like
glitch in and out so she's like not
there compared to the other puppets are
but they use the medium of Television
because last episode Sam saw these
puppets on TV so his understanding of
reality is just kind of affected by
everything around him but this imaginary
puppet version of Emma tells Sam that he
needs to stop hurting people and then
this scene switches back to real life
with real bodies Sam is covered in blood
surrounded by Bloody corpses and if you
look at all of them you see they were
killed exactly the way way Sam destroyed
those puppets Emma and Marie are
freaking out and talking through what
could be going on when Emma says why the
[__] are you scratching your neck like
Tyrone bighams yes this is a reference
to this Chappelle show character this
kind of dated reference is in keeping
with Emma's love of past media like
naming her Geral David Caruso because
she's a fan of the movie Jade or wearing
the Nirvana sweatshirt like even though
the people who write this show grew up
in the '90s and earlys and get all these
references just remember that the
character of Emma was born several years
after 9/11 yeah she'd be born in 2005
Marie uses her powers to sense that
there's blood clotted near her neck and
then rips the tracker out this is
similar to the tracker that vot put in
the members of the seven to keep tabs on
them unfortunately the first person
Marie tells about all this is Kate and
we get the big reveal Kate has been the
one making everyone forget in episode 4
Tech Knight told Kate that she was one
of the most powerful Heroes on campus
and she's really proving them right here
she managed to mind wipe Emma and three
of the soups in the top 10 and here you
can see her eye starts bleeding after
she pushes Marie so who knows how she
managed to do that to four people
without her head turning into bloody
mush we get a little reference to get
out with Dean shett stirring her tea
while listening to Kate talk about how
she doesn't want to keep doing this to
her friends Shetty pulls some parental
style manipulation all I've ever asked
is that you try use your gift for good
no matter how hot it
gets because you're the only one who can
keep your friends safe yikes now we know
from a previous episode that when Kate
first got her powers she accidentally
pushed her brother to walk into the
woods and never come back and after that
her parents didn't speak to her again so
shett is really finding the most
vulnerable students and using them to
her own ends Emma goes to meet up with
Sam and the sign for burgershack reads M
that is a tasty burger and not to Samuel
L Jackson and P fiction
mm this is a tasty burger there are
movie posters on the walls for payback
clueless and race to death which is a
new movie to the boys universe as far as
we know doesn't appear to be an a train
movie and payback doesn't have a
Speedster in it so we don't know whose
movie this is later k and Andre watch an
episode of the mesmerizer which is a VA
show starring Mesmer a telepathic soup
the adult version of Mesmer was played
by haly Joel osit it was killed by
butcher in season one of the boys and
just like haly Joel oset this implied
that he was a child actor but something
similar to Neil Patrick Harris as Doogie
Hower when he was a child actor or I
guess something like Dr Shawn Murphy
played by Freddy Highmore in the good
doctor meanwhile we see that Rufus is
also watching the mesmerizer I like how
much these college students love this
over 20-year-old serialized Mystery Show
Jordan and Marie confront him and he he
swears he didn't mind wipe them and we
get this hilarious classic reveal shot
you say I wiped your memory tonight
right except I couldn't have done that
because my powers only work up close and
I've been here for the last 5
hours please tell
them I'm pretty ipped on 2cb right now
but that sounds right 2cb is a club drug
similar to ecstasy or MDMA Emma calls
the others to warn them that Kate is
behind all this even making Luke forget
that he had a brother over and over
again this puts Luke's death in a whole
new light Emma says look I know Rufus is
a monster but so is Kate and then after
Kate gives Andre back his memories he
says you're a monster this has to be so
crushing to hear and crushing for us to
hear that Luke whispered I love you in
his ear Emma was so negatively affected
by her mother calling her a monster when
she was little that she spent years
suppressing half of her powers and now
Kate's closest friend is confirming one
of her worst fears that every teen has
Andre cries a single tear and Kate has
popped blood vessels in her eyes from
using her powers and we close this
episode on Annie lennox's I Put a Spell
on You playing over the credits it seems
like everyone at gulan is either
manipulating or being manipulated and
right now there are too many secrets to
even count so why does Dr cardosa say
that Marie could be the key to This
research and who is her mysterious
benefactor well there are a lot of
people who would have had an interest in
a soup with the ability to make people's
appendages explode maybe current bot CEO
Ashley on the lookout for a future
powerful member of the seven but if you
think about it Ashley's never really
been that much of a planner at least not
playing the long game she's just more of
a tactician responding moment to moment
she kind of just does whatever people
tell her to do it could be the CIA or
even the boys themselves who are always
looking for new weapons to take down the
corrupt soups but I think the one who
got Marie into gulkan despite Brink not
wanting her there and the one who has
been protecting her making sure she gets
into the top 10 could be former vot CEO
Stan Edgar Jean Carlo Esposito he has a
history with taking an interest in
orphan soups locked up in Red River he
essentially adopted Victoria Newman when
she was there and she accidentally
killed her parents in almost the exact
same way Marie killed her parents Edgar
would also be in need of a new weapon
since Victoria Newman turned on him and
got him fired from bot and the guy who
always has a contingency plan working
behind the scenes to plan for every
angle and give himself a leg up also
just seems like you know these
serialized TV shows that exist in IP
just love to bring back Esposito as like
the secret big bad who never goes away
now as far as Marie's Powers being the
key to cardo's research we've seen her
control blood both from expelling it and
putting it back into a body and she can
sense irregularities like the clotting
around the tracker so I think she'll
eventually be able to sense the compound
B within soup's blood and either rip it
out of them or burn it from them
essentially nullifying their powers and
turning them back into regular old
humans the only one we've seen who could
do anything like this was soldier boy
but that power was massively destructive
since he would simultaneously blow
everything up whenever he did this so
he's currently back in cryogenic Slumber
a soup who could depower other soups in
a relatively simple way would be
invaluable in this world and a risk to
almost every character we've seen in
both gen B and the boys let me know your
thoughts on this Theory and who you
think this mysterious benefactor is and
why Marie is so important in the
comments below thanks for watching this
breakdown of the boys subscribe to new
rock stars subscribe to the Deep dive
and the break room and you can support
us by grabing some merch over at nerd
ride. shop huge thanks to G bito and
Brandon baric for writing this breakdown
you can follow me at EA boss follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching
[Music]
bye
now